i would say be in the world invest in
your network
read relentlessly if someone asks you to
do something try and say yes which is
why i'm here
and i do tr you know and it drives my pa
completely mad because i do try
a lot of this because you you never know
you have two sort of mottos you never
know
you never know and the second one which
gets me into a lot of trouble is what's
the worst that can happen
right so
[Music]
debbie wasco thank you so much for
joining me how are you today yeah i'm
fine thank you thanks for having me from
london it's dark and cold here
i i love it it's uh it's dark and not
very cold in tel aviv
it's actually quite nice here in the in
the middle of winter but but
it's great to have you here i i can't
wait to talk about the sharing economy
which i know has been a topic of passion
of yours for quite some time but you've
had some really
incredible experiences with love home
swap which you
sold in in 2017 and then and with your
most recent company
and then you've started now with
albright from 2018 in the past two years
uh talking about the professional
network for women so a lot to talk about
but before all that i have to learn
about what it's like to get married
during a quarantine and covet
yeah so i had a locked down wedding in
london
um and i had that on about the last day
that it was possible to have
a wedding and it was small but perfectly
formed but actually
um so much love in the room and i think
for the people who were there it was one
of the first times that they had been
out or seen each other but the main
thing was that was
my second marriage and i have two
children
from my first marriage and my husband
has a child from his first marriage and
really it was their day so it was a big
party for them
but just um you know a real highlight in
a tough year that we've all had and
we'll always remember 2020 for good
reasons as well as difficult reasons
i i love that that's very inspiring
davey tell me a little bit about
about your your journey because it's
it's a really it's really interesting
journey
and looking from the side and then i'd
love to transition to hearing a little
bit more specifically about your
ventures and about the sharing
economy but take me all the way back to
oxford how do you get started with
with your entrepreneurial self and what
are some of the things that are guiding
you
as you're making your decisions to start
these organizations
you know it it's very hard to see the
narrative
in a life that's being lived um going
forwards but i think
you when you have some time to reflect
on your why i'm from a
family of entrepreneurs they wouldn't
class themselves as entrepreneurs
because that's quite a fancy word
but of business owners to self-starters
a jewish immigrant family to the uk i'm
third generation
and i grew up around people who work for
themselves i didn't know anybody
in my extended family who had a
conventional job
in particular the women in my family my
mother my grandmother who i was very
close to
who died age 97 a few years ago
were strong tenacious women who
controlled their own destiny
who ran businesses and were matriarchs
and that's very much i suppose the
the role model that i was very used to
and in those days
two things are quite important i think
everybody
talks about work and business around the
kitchen table and i'm very aware of that
with my own children that it was very
normal
to talk about work i spent a lot of my
formative years driving around with my
grandma
in her armored um vehicle which she
never learned how to reverse that's one
thing we have in common being terrible
dropping money off of the bank and you
know you it's what you see
so i think some of it is you have to see
it to be it particularly as the woman
the second thing is that um academic
excellence
is non-negotiable in that you
you know you have to work hard at school
and be a good student so i think those
two things are very formative but i do
think i
i set up my first business at 25
so um 21 years ago
and i think that um it de-risks
things if it's normalized to be part of
an entrepreneurial self-starting
community didn't feel risky
and if i look at my siblings and some
from a big family one of
five everybody works for themselves
actually well with my brother that the
next one but one excuse me um
he was also offered the same college as
me i've worked with him for over a
decade now
and my middle sister's a psychotherapist
but she runs
her own practice and she runs buildings
and she i i
i think so much of it is um on the
nature nurture
uh debate around um
normalization perhaps there's a bit in
the genes but i think it just
felt like what you did and i think for
women
if i link that to my career and my
business now albright
i think positive female role models who
um take risks right who um
show that it's possible to start
businesses in your 30s which is the mean
age to start a business which is often
when women are having children
i think really does make you see the art
of the possible and i think that's been
a big part of it for me
i love that talk to me a little bit
about the the love home swap so home
exchange what
even is that and how do you how do you
even get into being in the home swapping
market
you know i think you get different types
of entrepreneurs i'm quite
simple in many ways than that i can only
start and feel passionate about
businesses
that i can relate to and to some extent
where i am
the ultimate consumer that's not
everybody's
journey but it's mine so all of my
businesses have come from a position
of need or personal connection and then
i've home stopped story and this is the
real story
not just the sort of pr spin is that um
i went on holiday when my children were
tiny
um three months and two and for people
who have
young children who are listening those
holidays are pretty miserable
you know you sit in a hotel room with
the lights off of the watching a movie
with the sound off eating room service
and you're
feeding one on it and they're expensive
and they're not um a life lived well
and on the flight on the way back from
this holiday i watched the movie the
holiday
and which i actually re-watched this
christmas on does sort of hold up
which for those of you who haven't seen
it cameron diaz swapped homes with kate
winslet
and um it made me think a
inspiration can strike at any time so
you have to have eyes and ears
open and be in the world is what i
always say right
kids i think it's really important
because that's where it always comes
from for me but be it made me think
does that even exist because actually
the holiday that i wish i just had was
to stay in a home not a hotel
to swap frankly at that time my life
um with someone else's right
and i think particularly with small
children to be someone that was more
spacious and in a community
and this was exactly this was at the
very early days of airbnb
so the sharing economy which i later
became
i suppose the sort of queen of in the uk
i authored the wasco report
to advise the uk government and how to
regulate the sharing economy i was the
chair of sharing economy uk so that
sense of
of making more of the assets that you
own
and the skills that you have was a big
part of my life about five years but at
this stage nobody
nobody was thinking about it in that way
but i think there was the sense in which
we needed to make our assets sweat
harder
and we needed to think about perhaps
living life a bit differently
so the inspiration was the movie um i
suppose then the test is well what do
you do about it and i think what
entrepreneurs often have in common is
they need an itch to scratch they're
very relentless
um they don't let something drop the
test for me is always if it gives me
goosebumps or am i still
so i um just kept on like
i could sort of see it see the market
and then you know management consultant
from a million years ago
so i think you always then get taught to
analyze an opportunity and product
market fit i think it's always a
combination of
analytics and instinct for me um
right because my sisters are b2c
businesses so you've got to be able to
get something up and running and
consumer test it pretty quickly to check
it's a thing
i suppose this sort of typical point was
my brother ben
um he was about to go and do an mba um
and i dissuaded him from doing that and
said i've had this idea
why don't you come and do it with me for
six months i'll salary you is my
impoverished little brother and i had
already had
my marketing services business and that
was it so look at from the outside these
things look super
easy um in
equal measure it was hard
and riddled with mistakes
exhausting boring
give me an example of a mistake of a
mistake that you made that in hindsight
you're saying
i think that it takes and this would be
my if i'm to give any advice people
listening
to really find your sweet spot on
product market and pricing fit
just takes quite a long time right you
don't
just maybe some people do but i never do
so you're
always tweaking it what if it's this and
what if it's that and user testing is
like ah
you know and and we went down a few
blind alleys i think
the aha moment for love home swap
was around what what became known as the
three-way
swap in other words i'd say for at least
the first
year of the business we'd raised a
little bit of capital i'd funded that we
were you know
there was a thing but you could if i'm
in london and you're tel aviv
we could only swap with one another
right i think it was really
freeing up and developing the algo that
enabled
london to swap with television to swat
with paris
that then meant that this would be
a 365 day a year
you could bank credits and then i think
that was inflection point one inflection
point two
was realizing um
and this is why being in the world is
really important it was a bit like a
modern day time share
right you were essentially banking time
in your home as a tradable asset
to trade someone else and that was sort
of a moment
because i didn't know the timeshare
industry but then
i and i think this is another point
around commitment and total immersion
i really got to know the timeshare
industry i went to all the timeshare
conferences i was
in the room and what happened then and
i'm a great believer
in organized serendipity which is partly
when we've got albright i think is
really important
i spoke at the european timeshare
conference
on on why i thought home shopping was
the future of timeshare and i met
someone from windham the hotel group who
owned rci the timeshare business and
that was the exit right
so and i think there's there's a real
question mark
i i think around um
during the pandemic networks in
particular networks for women and that's
always been a big
passion that women's networks are not as
good as men and networks are how you get
done right
without words i didn't sell that
business without realizing okay hang on
i think it's this but actually it's this
so i would say be in the world
invest in your network read relentlessly
if someone asks you to do something try
and say yes which is why i'm here
and i do tr you know and it drives my pa
completely mad because i do try
a lot of this because you you never know
you have two sort of mottos you never
know
you never know and the second one which
gets me into a lot of trouble is what's
the worst that can happen right
so right in those two things you have to
put yourself out there and that was love
home swap
beginning to end five years exit
but honestly there were so many moments
where that could not have happened
unless you were in the room and you're
always trying to frame and reframe what
your business is
and you're not don't be
be passionately committed to the mission
right don't be 100
without openness committed to the
original
concept because it will it will change
it will just change you know and you
have to change with it
i love that the commitment to the
mission but also the commitment to being
able to change the concept
of how you execute on that mission
there's no weakness in that
and in the execution you know we pivot
i don't even think of it as a pivot it's
just life right we're always doing that
to try and and change it up uh
you know and i mean this sounds trite
and i don't want to sound right when
commenting on last year but
if life gives you lemons you've got to
make lemonade right and
you know i think that there's been a
huge opportunity
in the pandemic for businesses to really
think about how does their mission
support people within the pandemic right
what do consumers want
what do they need how can we best
service them how
and i think you can't i've watched
people
around me or businesses because i'm a
you know serial angel investor and
albright we run our female founders
pitch series so we have
four women pitching on two occasions a
month
every single month we see a lot of
entrepreneurs and my advice would be
you've got to roll with it and um and i
think a surprising amount of people
don't and you do have to
i i just love that and i have to say
that i completely agree nope
this whole show came about in in march
and the right at the
peak of the the first peak of the
pandemic you know i couldn't get into
the ubers and meet
interesting people in the valley so i
started meeting them on zoom and at the
end it was beautiful because
i i believe this is episode about 300 or
something that we're recording and
and it just it's pure lemonade that's
coming out of this and i'm so thankful
for people like you that are willing to
come on the show and share their
experience and insights debbie tell me a
little bit about about the sharing
economy and then i'd love to move
towards
talking about albright and the amazing
work that you're doing there for for
networking with women you know i i
suppose
my final point on the sharing economy
and people have the stomach for it you
know i wrote like a hundred thousand
words on this thing so you can go and
read it
um with huge
opportunity comes masses of
responsibility
that's life right so what was the
opportunity
that because of digital platforms
digital payment platforms you know
that's been the big game changer for the
sharing economy right
businesses like starting with paypal but
stripe that mean that
i can set up a platform and take money
in real time
anyone anywhere without going into too
much detail when we first started love
homeschool you couldn't do that right
so we were having like banking accounts
with money on
escrow 30-day payment you know
not possible everything's changed over a
decade
comes huge responsibility and as ever
you know and i'm a philosophy graduate
right so i like big questions
some existential questions what does it
mean to be
employed how should people work
what does the future of work look like
what are the responsibilities of
platforms
what does it mean to
be self-employed what's the
responsibility of the state
how do you know it's like really big
stuff
and i think that it's the most seismic
shift
of the last 50 years that we can
it's been exacerbated by the pandemic we
can work differently we have to work
differently
right it's a huge opportunity
it's an absolute radical shift in the
world of work
and it has the potential to create
massive problems
around ethics welfare and the way that
we look after people
so you know it's not an easy one but i
like that kind of thing
because i think that the more people
not just with theoretical brains but
with practical experience you can try
and think around those
um challenges the better and i think
that the relationship
between policy making and real life
entrepreneurial and frontline business
experience
matters and which i love i always have
something like that on the go at the
moment i'm on the mayor of london's
business board
i think that we should have a voice
we've got a response we can't complain
about the laws that are made across the
world if we're not
um standing up and being counted so i
always like to
stand up and be counted i i just love
that and i mean just a few words a
little bit about albright and why you're
spending your time now
working with this professional network
so look i guess the again with this sort
of benefit of hindsight sweep of history
thing
i'm so used to being the only woman in
the room that i don't even notice
anymore
right you're a woman who raises capital
then you are so in the minority you know
two percent of capital goes to back a
female founder
seven percent of investors are female
two percent at partner level
one and six in leadership positions in
corporates the stats for backing female
families are going down the pandemic has
made it work you know like
come on so i think to this point on
serendipity
and being in the world there were there
have been different points in my life
that changed your life different people
that you meet that change your life
that you have to be open to and i met
anna jones who's my co-founder in
albright
at a party four years ago a party i
nearly didn't go to
um and she was the ceo of hearst the
publishing
magazines business a mutual friend
introduced us and said duty should be
friends and
and the world changed because we bonded
over lots of things
life the universe everything kids the
same age um
we live in the same part of london you
know we like
high heels and sequin dresses whatever
but primarily
where are all the women became the theme
right and if we were going to set up a
business that combined
purpose with profit this is my fourth
business it's got to get me out of bed
in the morning the
one topic that i care about more than
anything
is driving gender equality and changing
the world of work for women
not just entrepreneurs but every woman
because it has not
changed fast enough um
so that's what albright's about is it's
called albright after the madeline
quote there's a special place in hell
for women who don't help other women
so our hypothesis is this that if women
have better networks
if they can upskill if they can access
capital
if they can build confidence and
resilience then we're going to change
the conversation for women at work so
it's a very i love that perspective
we want to build what we call a monster
global sisterhood of smart-minded
ambitious women
and and there are two parts of the
business physical space
which stands for something above and
beyond bricks and mortar challenging at
the moment
some open some shirt we've got buildings
in the states buildings here
and then what has been a massive
opportunity and hopefully a huge support
during the pandemic
is our digital platform so for anyone
listening i'm afraid you do have to be a
woman
to do this um but go into the app store
and find um the albright digital app
and um it's a paid product but you get
two weeks for free
and then it's 120 a year there's
tons of upskilling content in there and
anna and i wrote a book
called believe build become how to
supercharge your career that was out
last year which you should also check
out
and a lot of the contents on there right
so everything
how to negotiate a pay rise how to deal
with imposter syndrome
how to loads and loads and loads
of women and teaching and then there's a
community and that's
really important so it's linkedin meets
masterclass for women if you like
the community's got loads of groups it's
incredibly um
uh active and we have something called
sisterhood matching
which is like our online dating for
career women
amazing actually work with other women
around the world with similar interests
backgrounds
objectives so it's an incredibly vibrant
community
bigger best than ever because of the
pandemic and i would encourage all of
the women listening to this to check out
albright digital and also check out our
book which is very
practical so at the end of every chapter
we make you work
there's a lot of exercises you've got to
practice practice practice you know and
that's one of our
our key messages that it doesn't just
happen that you have to
work at this that for anna and i even
though it all looks
effortless every game everything from
you know dresses to delivery and we
would encourage other women to feel like
they can do the same
debbie i love that thank you for
thinking the inspiration by the way
that's exactly also the point that i
that's important for me to address in
this show you remember one of the first
questions that i asked was what are some
mistakes you've made
with with love home swap because i think
that's that's just such an integral part
of
of every journey and and sometimes we
forget when we look at these incredible
success stories that every success
it comes after a multitude of failures
small
perhaps failures but leading up to that
to those aha moments that at the end
seems so it seems so linear with the
narrative but like you said
it's much easier looking backwards than
ford's debbie before we finish i want to
thank you for being so generous with
your time and i'd love to ask the most
important question
which is three words that you would use
to describe yourself
gosh um i would say determined
tenacious and on a good day hopefully
fun
thank you very very much best of luck
with the dark cold london right now
and i can't wait to share this with the
world thank you thanks a lot